how's it going everyone
my name is Warren and welcome to my new
segment on my channel called Theory
Thursdays each week I get sent a ton of
theories from you all and I love it
whether that be on my email address in
the comments of some of my videos or on
my Instagram or Twitter and a lot of
them are really really good and I see
sometimes in the comments sections that
you enjoy reading other people's
theories so this segment that I will be
doing every Thursday is going to be all
about you all and the theories that you
come up with I thought this would be a
pretty cool way for me to interact with
you all and for you all to interact with
each other but it's also going to be a
fun competition so I'll explain to you
how Theory Thursdays are going to work
and of course I'll put the instructions
in the description down below so if you
have a theory of your own and you want
it to possibly end up on a Theory
Thursday segment all you have to do is
email it to me in the email in my
description cosmic Theory Thursdays at
gmail.com from each one submitted I will
choose about five to ten to talk about
each week then after you watch the video
comment down below with which theory you
thought was the best
I'll number each theory so you can just
comment on the number and why you
thought it was the best the theory with
the most votes will win that week then
at the end of the month out of all the
theories that one you'll choose which
one you like the most and they will win
the overall month and a prize right now
the prize will be an IMAX gift card so
you and a friend can go see Captain
Marvel or Avengers in game or whatever
you want in theaters and obviously a
shout out so that's how my new segment
Theory Thursday is going to work I have
some submitted for this week already
that I'll be talking about but be sure
to submit yours to have a chance to end
up on next week's Theory Thursday okay
so theory number one comes from Jillian
Brooke so Jillian says that in the
comics Nebula gets the gauntlet from
Thanos undoes the snap and then all of
the heroes come back and this is true if
you read the Infinity Gauntlet series
this is exactly what happens but she
goes on to state that she does not think
Marvel will do this in the MCU to bring
the characters back she says that the
Russo brothers have worked too hard to
protect the secrets of in games so it
doesn't make sense for the plot to be
something fans already know
this is true as well the Russo brothers
have come out and said that they're not
going to do what happened in the comics
because we do in fact already know the
story then and here's where the life
swap theory comes into play and how her
theory adds to that theory she goes on
to say that it's fair to say that every
character who survived the snap is
either a new character or has lost a
loved one or friend at some point Thor
lost Loki Tony lost Peter Parker Captain
America lost Bucky nebula Gamora Ikoyi
T'Challa rocket Groot etc etc so her
theory states that each character will
see her loved one who passed away much
like in Deadpool - she says that this
will happen inside of the soul stone cap
will switch with Bucky then afterwards
we get a beautiful shot of cap walking
into a ballroom and dancing with Peggy
and it's not faked this time so we will
get a heart throbbing interaction with
all of the characters as we say goodbye
to the first phase of heroes and make
way for the newbies to take charge of
the MCU she also adds that Pepper Potts
was totally about to tell Tony that he's
going to be a father
Peter was already like a son to Tony so
this would make Tony's switch with Peter
even more heartbreaking because it's
like Tony is choosing to stay alive for
one son or die for the other so that's
it for Jillian's theory this theory
definitely has some merits behind it and
honestly if we're going to lose some
heroes and Avengers in game it would be
nice if they went out in a really nice
way sacrificing themselves for loved
ones and also getting a really happy
ending like she mentioned the happy
ending for cap going back with Peggy
Carter
so that's theory number one going on to
theory number two theory number two
comes from you sir gleaming dust the
theory states that ant-man gets sucked
into a time vortex once he gets out of
the time vortex he goes to the Avengers
headquarters and finds out that he's
actually in the wrong time I agree with
this I definitely think that ant-man is
going to go into a time vortex and come
out in the wrong time once he gets out
and realizes that he's in the wrong time
he goes and finds Hank Pym and Janet Van
Dyne to figure out how to travel through
time vortexes once he figures it out he
goes back to the present time and finds
the remaining Avengers from there using
time travel the Avengers will go back to
the Battle of New York and begin to
change the events of the past and
Captain America will come up with a plan
to get the mine stone from Loki
this theory makes a lot of sense ant-man
is stuck in the quantum realm right now
he obviously has to get out somehow and
it could be through a time vortex after
all they did mention it in the
post-credits scene of ant-man and the
wasp and it makes sense to go back to
the Battle of New York and get the mind
stone from Loki so that's theory number
two now on to theory number three theory
number three comes from a 16 year old
living in India named Dutch and by the
way I'm very sorry if I pronounced
anyone's name wrong Dutch's theory is
very simple and to the point Tony Stark
will have to make a very big sacrifice
similar to the one that he did in the
first Avengers film and he will also
create a suit that lets him wield all of
the Infinity stones I definitely think
that in one way or another the sacrifice
part is true and I also think that Tony
Stark will indeed have to make a suit
that's capable of wielding all of the
Infinity stones
even though Thanos completely destroyed
the Avengers and Avengers infinity war I
still think that people underestimate
just how strong he is you have to be a
being of incredible power to even we'll
just one Infinity stone in fact an
infinity war evany Maus says that nobody
has ever wielded more than one Infinity
stone Thanos was the first person so
it's not like somebody can just throw on
the Infinity Gauntlet and undo the snap
they won't be strong enough to handle it
but if Tony can somehow create a suit
that harnesses and distributes the power
of the Infinity stones perhaps he could
survive the power of the stones and undo
the snap but even if Tony did undo the
snap I still don't think he'd be
powerful enough to survive the power it
takes to perform the snap therefore
sacrificing himself to save the universe
so I do think that Tony is going to have
to make some sort of sacrifice and
Avengers in game and he could possibly
make a suit to wield all of the Infinity
stones
moving on to theory number four theory
number four comes from user infinity
Ewok his theory states that Tony and
nebula lose all hope but Captain Marvel
arrives and leads them to a collapsing
neutron star inside of an einstein-rosen
bridge much like The Devil's anus and
thor ragnarok this will take them only a
short distance from Earth and then
Pepper Potts will come and save them in
her rest
you armored Tony gets back to earth and
meanwhile Steve Natasha
Bruce Thor roadie and rocket are at the
Avengers compound Scott arrives and he
is let in once he finds out about the
snap he tells them that he was stuck
inside of the quantum realm and escaped
through a time vortex from here they
will try to figure out time travel but
during this time Black Widow goes off to
find Hawkeye in Japan she finds him and
he says how his family was lost in the
snap and that he left to talk with
sacred people similar to how Doctor
Strange became a sorcerer but instead of
the ability to manipulate energy Clint
can now identify scrolls and other
aliens that are impersonating humans I
think that in this theory there are a
lot of things that can happen Captain
Marvel is definitely one of the people
who could rescue Tony Stark if they are
super far away from home which it seems
like they are the einstein-rosen bridge
could definitely be a way to get them
closer to earth and we've already seen
leaked photos of Pepper Potts in her
rescue armor so I think it's safe to
assume that she'll wear it at some point
in time in Avengers endgame the last
part about Hawkeye somehow being able to
detect scrolls is very interesting we
know that he goes to Japan to hunt down
the Yakuza there's been talk that the
reason he's going to Japan to hunt down
the Yakuza is because they are in fact
Skrulls but how does he know who the
Skrulls are well maybe he does get the
power to be able to detect who they are
weirder things have happened now on to
the last theory theory number 5 the last
theory comes from user captain Baylor
the theory states that in guardians of
the galaxy volume 1 the guardians get
arrested they show all the Guardians one
by one showing facts based on their
criminal records and where star Lord did
his iconic middle finger crank I'm sorry
I didn't know how this machine worked on
a bunch of a hose transports all Fords
the kill when they show Gomorrah they
state that she was the last one of her
species and the infinity war movie
Thanos is said to have killed half of
the population
why would Marvel make a mistake about
her storyline the theory is that Gamora
will actually have her own storyline
much like past movies like Ant Man and
Captain America they might show the
relationship between Gamora and nebula
and how Gamora became an assassin or
even how her people may have done the
same exact thing the Avengers are doing
now getting revenge on Thanos this is
actually something that people have been
wondering since Avengers infinity war
came out like Captain Beiler stated in
guardians of the galaxy vol 1 they say
that Gamora is the last of her species
but in infinity war we see that Thanos
actually only killed half of the
population and he even says that the
planet is now a paradise and is thriving
the Russo brothers actually did a Q&A
with Collider where one fan brought this
to their attention and asked what the
deal was the Russo brothers actually
replied who do you believe Thanos or
Gamora so they implied that one of them
is lying
perhaps Gamora will get her own
storyline maybe in Avengers in game or
in guardians of the galaxy vol 3 or
maybe even in a separate movie
altogether
Thanos went planet to planet and killed
half of the populations of these planets
without any warning whatsoever you have
to imagine that out of all the many many
planets that he visited eventually one
of them would seek revenge against him
and perhaps that could be gamora's home
planet so maybe there is a story arc
that we are missing here but may see
later on down the road in the MCU so
those are all the theories for today's
Theory Thursday be sure to vote on your
favorite one by commenting the number of
the one that you liked the most and of
course if you have a theory that you
came up with yourself and would like to
submit email it to me in the theory
Thursday email address down below again
I did this so I could interact with you
all more and so you could all interact
with each other more so please try to be
kind when you're commenting on other
people's theories we're all here for the
same reason because we love Marvel we
love DC and all things related to
superheroes let me know what you think
about this new segment and let me know
which Theory you thought was the best be
sure to subscribe to stay up to date on
all the
Thursday's and so you can say up-to-date
on everything related to Marvel and DC
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]